By recent blood test shows a serum ferritin of 7, so the serum ferritin of 7 is low.
I would like to know if you have ever heard of the research by Mori Robbins at his new book, Copper Cure for Fatigue.
But I don't have fatigue. He has been researching this for 10 years and discusses the critical role of copper in regulated iron.
Prior to this, I had high iron. My doctor has ordered a copper test at a seroplasm test and magnesium red blood cell test. Any comment on all of this?
Well, serum ferritin of 7 is low and usually that has to do with some sort of anemia.
It doesn't always have to do with an iron, anemia, meaning that your iron levels can be normal to this person that said their iron levels are actually elevated.
It can be a B12 anemia as well. That can cause a ferritin level of low.
B12 anemia or a prodigious anemia can be caused from a genetic factor, the genes that help you bring iron across the gut wall.
More commonly it's caused from issues with your gut, you know, needing some gut healing because you have some gut damage.
Now, commenting on the copper, the cure for fatigue, I would be very careful about that because there is a whole another phenomenon with copper.
People can get way too much copper and end up with copper toxicity and copper and zinc have a very definitive relationship within your body.
If you have excess copper stored in your tissues, that can lead, that can be a major thing that leads to cancer.
So, one of the things you test for in cancer patients quite often is your copper zinc ratio because it's usually off, you have excess copper and low zinc.
People commonly have a zinc deficiency, especially with excess copper, that if you start taking zinc, you can get zinc because you will dump, you will push copper out of the cells and you can become, you can, you can feel will flourish even.
You're getting like a verksima reaction because you're dumping excess copper that could be so harmful to your cells.
So, I'm not a big fan of taking excess copper, all of our cancer members, we don't let them take supplements with copper.
So, copper can drive cancer, copper is a, what is copper, you need copper, understand, but you should get that in your vegetables, I don't think you should be taking copper in your supplements.
So, a lot of multiple vitamins will have a milligram of copper in there which is the daily, you know, recommended allowance of copper, which I guess that's fine, but even with our cancer patients, I don't want them to get anything more than that with copper because copper is a growth factor, copper increases growth.
I don't know what they're cancer, but you certainly don't want that with anything else either.
So, I'm not a big fan of taking copper at all, so, you know, I just, not a big fan of that work, just with what I've seen.
So, a lot of people can have issues, more issues with excess copper than issues with too low of copper.
Remember, with any of the minerals, you really need to be careful, even if you're taking minerals, you want to make sure the way that the supplement is that you are, that it's key laden correctly.
Let me explain, there was a big bad going on a couple of years ago that, you know, we need to be cooking with cast-iron pans because it's so good for you because cast-iron pans are iron, and that's a good way to get your iron.
That, in fact, they came out with these little eye cast-iron, little, like, little duck or a cast-iron, little chicken, and you should put it in your, when you're boiling water for potatoes, throw that right in your pot because then you'll get some iron from that cast-iron, leach into your potatoes, and that will be good for you.
Or the whole claim of cooking with cast-iron because now you're getting iron and iron deficiency as an issue and that's good for you.
Well, the only truth of that is that, yeah, iron deficiency can be a problem, but we are not supposed to be eating elemental iron.
We're not supposed to be eating iron in the floor of ferrous that is in an iron cookware or cast-iron doily thing that you put into your pot of water.
That is not how we get our iron. We don't get our minerals from the soil. We don't eat dirt to get our minerals.
We eat plants to get our minerals. Plants eat dirt, and they convert minerals in the soil to a double bonded, it's key-lated to an amino acid through a double bond.
That's how we should eat our minerals. That's how it's well absorbed, and that's how it could get into ourselves.
Taking iron or any minerals in a poorly-key-lated form can actually cause disease. It then is acting like a heavy metal in our body, and it's damaging to ourselves.
It has to be double bonded to an amino acid, or do you get that? Well, you get it in your plants.
However, good supplement companies use a nutritional formulator called TRAX-T-R-A-A-C-S, I think it is, and there's another company that does it. They actually have two names.
One bought out the other one, and that's the good nutritional companies only use those to formulate their minerals, so it'll be like iron as iron by glycinate, or it'll be instead of calcium carbonate, which is limestone from dirt.
It'll be calcium lactate, or calcium that's double bonded to an amino acid, calcium glycinate.
Most magnesiums out there on the market are correctly key-lated. If you go buy something from Walmart or Target, that's where you're going to get these.
That's what is a garbage supplement, because the minerals are just made from cleaned dirt, cleaned earth, and you can't assimilate those through the gut.
They can actually be damaging to the gut, and the things that the minerals that do absorb through the gut in the bloodstream can actually be damaging to the blood vessels, and can cause bone spurs and all sorts of stuff.
You have to get your minerals the proper way, and you see that with copper, too. The whole big fat, a couple of years ago, is where are these copper bracelets?
Well, because it's copper, but it's elemental copper. That's what you're supposed to suck on a copper pipe for crying out loud. It's poisonous. That's a heavy metal. That's toxic.
It just doesn't make any sense. So, is that good to not know?
Just think of it this way. I always tell, I always tell people that lecturer nutrition is that eat things the way God intended us to eat things.
We're not supposed to go out there eat dirt. Plants eat dirt. We eat plants.
So, if you can think of it that way, it's better. And if you think of any of your supplements that you're taking, you want them as close to the way God created it, that's the better way to do it.
Most good supplement company that only sells to professionals is selling good stuff like that. There's just a lot of garbage stuff out there for the public, for the unknown public.
And that's why it's cheaper. Hey, well, I was going to buy your minerals, but they're $32 a bottle. And I got these at Target for 15. Well, yeah, well, you get what you're paying for.